¿Cómo es posible? No saben nada".
Mis colegas dijeron: "No, es una solución simple.
Seguro que uno de tus estudiantes ha pasado por aquí
y les enseñó cómo usar el ratón".
Y yo: "Sí, es posible".
Así que repetí el experimento. Me fui a casi 500 km de Delhi
a un pueblo muy apartado
donde las posibilidades de que pasara un ingeniero de software
eran muy remotas. (Risas)
Repetí allí el experimento.
No había lugar para quedarse, así que coloqué mi computadora,
me fui, volví un par de meses después,
y encontré niños jugando con ella a videojuegos.
Cuando me vieron, dijeron:
"queremos un procesador más rápido y un ratón mejor".
(Risas)
Así que dije: "¿cómo narices saben todo esto?"
Y me dijeron algo muy interesante.
Con voz irritada, dijeron:
"nos diste una máquina que sólo funciona en inglés,
así que tuvimos que enseñarnos inglés para poder usarla". (Risas)
Esa fue la primera vez, como profesor,
que escuché la palabra "enseñarnos" dicha tan a la ligera.
Aquí podemos echar un vistazo de esos años.
Ese es el primer día en "Agujero en la pared"
A su derecha hay un niño de ocho años.
A su izquierda está su alumna. Ella tiene seis años.
Y le está enseñando cómo navegar.
Luego por otras partes del país,
repetí esto una y otra vez,
obteniendo exactamente los mismos resultados que teníamos.
[Película: "Agujero en la pared", 1999]
Una niña de ocho años diciéndole a su hermana mayor qué debe hacer.
Y finalmente una niña explicando en la lengua maratí qué es
y dice "hay un procesador dentro".
Así que empecé a publicar.
Publiqué en todas partes. Anoté y medí todo,
y expliqué: en nueve meses, un grupo de niños
a solas con una computadora en cualquier idioma
llegarán al mismo nivel que una secretaria en Occidente.
He visto que sucedía esto una y otra vez.
Pero tenía curiosidad por saber, ¿qué otra cosa podrían hacer
si podían hacer ya tanto?
Empecé a experimentar con otras materias,
entre ellas, por ejemplo, la pronunciación.
Hay una comunidad de niños en el sur de India
cuya pronunciación del inglés es muy mala
y necesitaban una buena pronunciación, ya que mejoraría sus trabajos.
Les instalé un convertidor de voz a texto en una computadora
y les dije: "Sigan hablando hasta que la computadora escriba lo que Uds. dicen".
(Risas)
Y lo hicieron, vean un poco.
Computadora: Gusto en conocerlo. Niño: Gusto en conocerlo.
Sugata Mitra: La razón por la que terminé con la cara
de esta joven de allí es porque sospecho que muchos de Uds. la conocen.
Ella entró a un centro de llamadas en Hyderabad
y puede que los haya torturado por sus tarjetas de crédito
en un acento inglés muy claro.
Así que la gente se preguntaba, ¿hasta dónde llegará?
¿Dónde se detendrá?
Decidí que destruiría mi propio argumento
al crear una proposición absurda.
Planteé una hipótesis, una hipótesis ridícula.
El tamil es una lengua autóctona del sur y dije:
¿pueden los niños de lengua tamil en una aldea del sur de India
aprender la biotecnología de la replicación del ADN en inglés
mediante una computadora puesta en la calle?
Y pensé: los evaluaré. Obtendrán un cero.
Lo dejaré un par de meses, lo voy a dejar un par de meses.
Volveré, obtendrán otro cero.
Volveré al laboratorio y diré que necesitamos profesores.
Encontré un pueblo. Kallikuppam, al sur de India.
Coloqué ahí computadoras en el "Agujero en la pared";
descargué todo tipo de cosas desde Internet sobre la replicación del ADN,
la mayoría de los cuales yo no entendía.
Los niños llegaron corriendo, dijeron: "¿qué es todo esto?"
Así que les dije: "Es de gran actualidad, muy importante. Pero todo está en inglés".
Ellos dijeron: "¿Cómo podemos entender esas palabras inglesas tan grandes
y los diagramas y la química?"
Para ese momento, había desarrollado un nuevo método pedagógico,
así que lo apliqué. Les dije: "No tengo ni la más remota idea".
(Risas)
"Y, de todos modos, me voy".
Los dejé un par de meses.
Obtuvieron un cero. Les hice una prueba.
Volví tras dos meses
y los niños aparecieron y dijeron: "No hemos entendido nada".
Así que me dije: "¿qué esperaba yo?"
Les dije: "Está bien, pero ¿cuánto tiempo les llevó
decidir que no habían entendido nada?
Ellos dijeron: "No nos dimos por vencidos.
Lo vemos todos los días".
Así que le dije: "¿Cómo? No entienden estas pantallas
y se quedan mirándolas durante dos meses? ¿Para qué?"
Una niña que se ve en este momento,
levantó la mano y me dijo en inglés y tamil deficiente:
"Bueno, aparte del hecho
de que la replicación indebida de la molécula de ADN provoca enfermedades,
no hemos entendido nada más".
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Así que los puse a prueba.
Tengo una imposibilidad educativa, de cero a 30 %
en dos meses, bajo el calor tropical,
con una computadora bajo el árbol en un idioma desconocido
haciendo algo que se adelanta una década a su tiempo.
Absurdo. Pero tenía que seguir la norma victoriana.
El 30 % es un fracaso.
¿Cómo puedo hacer que aprueben? Tengo que conseguir 20 puntos más.
No podía encontrar un profesor. Lo que sí encontré fue una amiga que tenía
una hija de 22 años, contable,
y que jugaba con ellos todo el tiempo.
Así que le pregunté a la chica: "¿Puedes ayudarme?"
Ella me dijo: "Claro que no.
No tuve ciencias en la escuela. No tengo ni idea
de lo que hacen bajo ese árbol durante todo el día. No te puedo ayudar".
Le dije: "Te diré qué. Usa el método de la abuela".
Ella me dice: "¿Qué es eso?"
Le dije: "Ponte de pie detrás de ellos.
Cada vez que hagan algo, solo di
'bueno, vaya, ¿cómo hicieron eso?
¿Cuál es la siguiente página? Cielos, a su edad yo nunca podría haber hecho eso'.
Ya sabes lo que hacen las abuelas".
Ella hizo eso dos meses más.
Los resultados subieron a 50 %.
Kallikuppam había alcanzado
a mi escuela control de Nueva Delhi,
una escuela privada rica con un profesor formado en biotecnología.
Al ver ese gráfico sabía que hay una forma de nivelar el campo de juego.
Aquí está Kallikuppam.
(Niños hablando) Las neuronas... comunicación.
Tengo el ángulo equivocado de la cámara. Es solo material de aficionado,
pero lo que ella decía, como pudieron entender,
era sobre las neuronas, con sus manos así,
y decía que las neuronas se comunican.
Con 12 años.
Entonces, ¿cómo serán los trabajos?
Bueno, ya sabemos cómo son hoy.
¿Cómo será el aprendizaje? Sabemos cómo es hoy,
niños inmersos en sus teléfonos móviles por un lado
yendo a regañadientes a la escuela llevando sus libros con la otra mano.
¿Cómo será mañana?
¿Será que ya no tendremos que ir a la escuela?
¿Podría ser que, en el momento en que necesiten saber algo,
lo pueden averiguar en dos minutos?
¿Podría ser?... una pregunta devastadora,
una pregunta que me planteó Nicholas Negroponte...
¿podría ser que nos estemos dirigiendo hacia o tal vez estemos
en un futuro en el que el saber está obsoleto?
Pero eso es terrible. Somos Homo sapiens.
El saber es lo que nos distingue de los simios.
Pero véanlo de esta manera.
A la naturaleza le llevó 100 millones de años
hacer que los simios se irguieran
y se convirtieran en Homo sapiens.
Nos costó sólo 10 000 años para que el saber se convirtiera en obsoleto.
Qué logro es esto.
Pero tenemos que integrar eso en nuestro propio futuro.
El estímulo parece ser la clave.
Si se fijan en Kuppam,
si se fijan en todos los experimentos que hice,
simplemente decía: "Guau", saludando al aprendizaje.
Hay evidencia de la neurociencia.
La parte reptil de nuestro cerebro localizada en el centro,
cuando se siente amenazado, apaga todo lo demás,
se apaga la corteza prefrontal, la parte del aprendizaje,
apaga todo eso.
Los castigos y los exámenes son vistos como amenazas.
Tomamos a nuestros niños, les hacemos apagar sus cerebros
y luego les decimos: "Funciona bien".
¿Por qué crearon un sistema así?
Porque se necesitaba.
Hubo una época en la Edad de los Imperios
en que se necesitaba a aquellas personas que pudieran sobrevivir bajo amenaza.
Cuando se está en una trinchera solo,
si uno puede sobrevivir, está bien, aprobado.
Si uno no lo logró, no aprobado.
Pero la Edad de los Imperios se acabó.
¿Qué sucede con la creatividad en nuestra época?
Tenemos que desplazar el equilibrio
de la amenaza al placer.
Volví a Inglaterra en busca de abuelas británicas.
Puse avisos y documentos que decían:
Si Ud. es una abuela británica, si tiene banda ancha y una cámara web,
¿me podría regalar una hora de su tiempo a la semana?
Conseguí 200 en las primeras dos semanas.
Conozco más abuelas británicas que nadie en el universo. (Risas)
Se llaman la nube de abuelas.
La nube de abuelas se sienta en Internet.
Si hay un niño con problemas, lanzamos una abuela.
Ella aparece en Skype y ordena las cosas.
Las he visto hacerlo desde un pueblo llamado Diggles
en el noroeste de Inglaterra,
al interior de un aldea en Tamil Nadu, India,
a casi 10 000 km.
Lo hace con un solo gesto antiquísimo.
"Shhh".
¿De acuerdo?
Vean esto.
Abuela: No me puedes atrapar. Díganlo Uds.
No me puedes atrapar.
Niños: No me puedes atrapar.
Abuela: Soy el hombre de jengibre. Niños: Soy el hombre de jengibre.
Abuela: ¡Bien hecho! Muy bien.
SM: ¿Qué está pasando aquí?
Creo que lo que tenemos que mirar es
al aprendizaje
como el producto de la autoorganización educacional.
Si se permite que el proceso educativo se autoorganice,
entonces surge el aprendizaje.
No se trata de hacer que el aprendizaje ocurra.
Se trata de dejar que suceda.
El profesor pone en marcha el proceso
y luego se pone de pie de nuevo con asombro
y observa como el aprendizaje ocurre.
Creo que a eso apunta todo esto.
Pero, ¿cómo lo sabremos? ¿Cómo vamos a llegar a saberlo?
Bueno, intento construir
estos Entornos de Aprendizaje Auto-Organizados. [EAAO]
Son, básicamente, Internet de banda ancha, colaboración
y estímulo colocados juntos.
Lo he intentado en muchas escuelas, muchos años.
Ha sido probado en todo el mundo y los profesores
dan una suerte de paso atrás y dicen: "¿Surge por sí mismo?"
Y yo: "Sí, surge por sí mismo". Y ellos: "¿Cómo lo sabes?"
Y yo: "No creerás qué niños me lo dijeron
y de dónde son".
Aquí hay un EAAO en acción.
(Niños hablando)
Este está en Inglaterra.
Él mantiene la ley y el orden
porque, recuerden, no hay un profesor cerca.
Chica: El total de electrones no es igual a la cantidad total de protones - SM: Australia
Chica: dándole un neto positivo de carga eléctrica negativa.
La carga neta de un ión es igual a la cantidad de protones
en el ión menos el número de electrones.
SM: Una década por delante de su tiempo.
Son EAAOs, creo que necesitamos un plan de estudios de grandes preguntas.
Ya han oído hablar de eso. Saben lo que eso significa.
Hubo un tiempo en el que los hombres y mujeres de la Edad de Piedra
solían sentarse, mirar al cielo y decir:
"¿Qué son esas luces parpadeantes?"
Construyeron el primer plan de estudios, pero hemos olvidado estas preguntas maravillosas.
Lo hemos reducido a la tangente de un ángulo.
Pero eso no es lo suficientemente atractivo.
La forma de decírselo a un niño de nueve años es:
"Si un meteorito fuera a chocar con la Tierra,
¿cómo saber si chocará o no?"
Y si él dice: "Bueno, ¿qué?, ¿cómo?"
Uds. dicen: "Hay una palabra mágica. Se llama la tangente de un ángulo"
y lo dejan en paz. Él va a averiguarlo.
Así que aquí hay un par de imágenes de los EAAOs.
He probado preguntas increíbles.
"¿Cuándo comenzó el mundo? ¿Cómo terminará?",
a niños de nueve años.
Esta es sobre qué sucede con el aire que respiramos.
Esto lo han hecho los niños sin la ayuda de ningún profesor.
El maestro solo plantea la cuestión
y luego retrocede y admira la respuesta.
¿Cuál es mi deseo?
Mi deseo es
que diseñemos el futuro del aprendizaje.
No queremos ser repuestos
de una gran computadora humana excelente, ¿verdad?
Así que tenemos que diseñar un futuro para el aprendizaje.
Y tengo que... esperen,
tengo que decir esto correctamente,
porque, ya saben, es muy importante.
Mi deseo es ayudar a diseñar un futuro de aprendizaje
mediante el apoyo a los niños de todo el mundo
aprovechando su asombro y su capacidad de trabajar juntos.
Ayúdenme a construir esta escuela.
Se va a llamar la escuela en la nube.
Va a ser una escuela donde los niños se adentrarán a aventuras intelectuales
impulsados por las grandes preguntas planteadas por sus mediadores.
La forma en que quiero hacerlo
es construir una instalación donde pueda estudiar esto.
Es una instalación que prácticamente no tiene personas.
Solo hay una abuelita
que gestiona la salud y la seguridad.
El resto es de la nube.
La nube enciende y apaga las luces,
etc., etc., todo se hace desde la nube.
Pero los quiero para otro propósito.
Pueden hacer Entornos de Aprendizaje Auto-Organizado
en casa, en la escuela, fuera de la escuela, en clubes.
Es muy fácil de hacer. Hay un gran documento
producido por TED que les dice cómo hacerlo.
Si lo desean, por favor, por favor háganlo
en los cinco continentes
y me envían los datos,
entonces lo pondré todo junto, y lo colocaré en la escuela en la nube,
y crear el futuro del aprendizaje.
Ese es mi deseo.
Y una última cosa.
Los llevaré a la cima del Himalaya.
A 3600 m , donde hay poco aire,
donde una vez empotré dos computadoras en el agujero en la pared
y los niños acudían allí.
Y había una niña que me seguía.
Y yo le dije: "Sabes, quiero darle una computadora a todos, a todos los niños.
No sé, ¿qué debería hacer?"
Y yo estaba tratando de tomar una foto de ella discretamente.
De pronto levantó la mano, así, y me dijo:
"Hazlo".
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Creo que fue un buen consejo.
Seguiré su consejo. Dejaré de hablar.
Gracias. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias. (Aplausos)
Muchas gracias. ¡Guau! (Aplausos)